there's Stewart branch long now
foundation well tonight is a little bit
about averting the collapse of at least
government there's a firm at of dismay
lately on you know government is broken
usually what people mean as the Senate
is broken or the California Legislature
is broken or the process by which voters
put forward peculiar propositions is
broken but the way government gets
broken is not just with votes but by
whole levels of participation that Beth
Novick is taking an angle on both with
the kind of philosophy of open
government and what's especially
interesting to an audience like this is
basically the techniques and technology
of open government
please welcome doesn't over
thank you to Stuart and thank you to the
long now foundation I am thrilled to be
back in San Francisco and to have the
chance to talk to you tonight it will
not be six easy steps I think it is many
more very difficult steps to try to
rebuild and remake our government to
reshape our government and bring change
to the way it works to make it more
effective more efficient and to better
serve us the American people but I want
to start my story a little bit further
back in Florence in the year 14 21 when
filippo brunelleschi whose work we've
all gone to admire in the domes of
Florence as tourists received a
three-year patent for a barge with
hoisting gear that carried marble along
the Arno River
it was one of the earliest patents and
of course then in Venice the process of
patenting proliferated over the course
of the fifteenth century and the glass
makers of Venice received patents again
for the process of creating glass and as
Venetians began to emigrate the idea of
patenting of getting monopolies on the
way that glass was manufactured diffused
and and spread to other countries
countries for example like England where
of course the monarchs and rulers of
England and again and through countries
throughout Europe we're in the habit of
granting patents largely as a way to
raise funds for the crown two favorite
persons who were prepared to pay for
them to have the monopoly rights to
manufacture whether it was not simply
new will invent shion's but even
ordinary inventions like salt and so the
reality of invention and innovation
became disconnected from the
institutional practice the abusive
institutional practice of granting
monopolies and after a public outcry the
institution was of course reformed and
James the first of England was forced to
forego the his process of his right of
granting patents and in 1623 Parliament
declared the statute of monopolies which
restricted the pounds crowd the Crown's
power to actually issue patents and
began to then systematize and regularize
the process of giving to inventors the
patent of a certain number of years over
their inventions so this spreads of
course then to the
it comes over from England and the
patent Clause of the Constitution many
of you may know article 1 section 8
Clause 8 the talks about securing for
limited times to authors and inventors
the exclusive right to their respective
writings and discoveries this is the
only clause in the Constitution that's
enacted without any debate because it is
by this time common practice to have a
patent system and it was long the
practice not only in England but of
course have been the practice in the
States before then and becomes adopted
then by the federal government largely
as a way to resolve contentious fights
that are going on among the states over
patents over the steamship and steamship
technologies but also because it's a
really cheap way for the now bankrupt
federal government to give this right to
inventors by giving them a private right
to say you can go out with this monopoly
and exploit it it doesn't cost us
anything we don't have any money because
we've got to pay back this Revolutionary
War debt so why don't you go ahead and
so is enacted without debate this clause
in the Constitution but in fact this
system becomes broken as well Thomas
Jefferson as you may know was not only
Secretary of State but also the first
head of the Patent Office and he has in
addition all the other things he's doing
has to examine 33 zero patents that are
waiting for him to review and it's too
much work for him so he says forget this
patent examination system we're gonna
switch to a registration system
basically pay your feet get a stamp you
get a patent so on 40 years later in
1836 we say well this is again we have
this disconnect between the reality of
innovation and the idea of granting
patents and so we evolved from the
system of abusive monarchical control in
our constitutional republic we evolved a
kind of routinized system of creating of
issuing patents but once again we find
ourselves at a point of disconnect where
this system isn't working the office
that is supposed to be the office of
innovation is mired in bureaucracy we
have backlogs piles of paper which I'm
pleased to report that the new head of
our patent office David Kappas is
working hard to reduce and is bringing
down this backlog but we have 700,000
backlog patents which haven't been
examined
with examiner's who have at most between
18 to 20 hours to actually read all the
literature review the patent and decide
whether it deserves a 20 year grant of
Monopoly rights to become the new iPod
or cancer curing a life-saving cure or
whatever important invention it may be
and these are being done by people who
have in many cases a BA and a science
and maybe not even in the science of the
patent which they are examining and this
has serious social consequences
diverting large amounts of money away
from scientific R&D that could be used
and put back into discovering those
cures for cancer and instead being sent
over to the lawyers like me and the
students which I train so they are in
fact diverting potentially money away
from developing innovation and into a
system instead of litigation so this is
just one example I think one of many of
the way in which government institutions
have been what I would call at risk of
creating a single point of failure in
other words we're concentrating
decision-making power in the hands of
too few people whether legislators in
Congress or cabinet officials in the
executive branch or bureaucrats in
agencies like the Patent Office but we
construct our institutional practices
around this notion that this is the best
way that we have to make decisions that
we can have to entrust these important
public decisions to government decision
makers at one remove from the biases of
public participation and in fact this is
however we are even though we are moving
away from you know we not have a system
of monarchy or aristocracy but we still
believe in this notion I think
institutionally of the notion of
political expertise and the notion that
we have to wrest power at the center and
what exacerbates this problem and we
were discussing this today is that we
are making very long-term decisions that
affect the fate of our planet the fate
of our economy the fate of our major
systems of health care and education are
being made by people who are in very
short-term political positions so we
have a disconnect between the long term
effect of what we do and the short-term
electoral cycles the characterize the
way that we tend to make decisions in
our government but this president my
President Barack Obama has talked about
myriad times the fact to quote him that
the best ideas don't come from
Washington and that from fact we have to
look at the ways we can re-engineer our
institutions to look at taking advantage
of the expertise that comes outside from
outside the center from the periphery
and bring it into the way that we make
decisions if you will in the center it
has very serious consequences if we
don't do this we're witnessing the
disconnect now you know an approval rate
of Congress now that's about flat on a
good day at about 25 percent and that is
often less than that but the faith in
government the trust in government
institutions is at an all-time low and
it's understandable if you think about
the serious threats that we face whether
from global pandemics
or international terrorism that that
organizations and institutions that are
built on a 19th century conception of
sovereignty and 19th century
nation-states and borders don't fit with
the kind of global porous distributed
threats that we face today and so this
fear that we have that Madison worried
about in Federalist 10 where he worried
about the factionalism in American
politics and the factionalism that would
happen from the rabble is in fact
happening when we have such a disconnect
between what happens in the center and
what happens at the periphery the
centralization in power is in fact
potentially driving a factionalized and
disgruntled and increasingly
dissatisfied and distressing public
where participation and power are
increasingly being driven apart and the
distance between the citizen and the
government that works for him is
increasing which is compelling
government intern to adopt or was until
now
less participatory institutions that in
turn fuels this process of
dissatisfaction a process that I think
we see reflected now in a kind of
reactionary populism that's springing up
in the Tea Party movement in the United
States or anti-immigrant nationalist
part
in Europe we're seeing the kind of
alienating forces that are at work at
the moment but coming back to our good
friend Jefferson for the moment he of
course knew everything that there was to
know and he was way ahead of his time
when he was heading up the Patent Office
in 1791 he writes to his good friend a
professor at the University of
Pennsylvania and he says I have a
problem I have this patent application
sitting on my desk for a alchemy process
alchemical process and I don't really
know how to examine it I would be so
obliged as your most humble servant if
you would actually help me to review
this patent application he took
advantage of the distributed expertise
that was available to him mind you he
used a letter and not the Internet at
that point but we too are now coming to
recognize the opportunities that are
available to us if we take advantage of
today's technology the technology that's
allowing us to come together in new ways
to work together increasingly powerfully
as groups on the Internet as purposive
groups if we can take advantage of this
power for the benefit of our political
institutions so you've heard lectures
here and elsewhere and discussion of
course about the re-engineering of the
music industry and the publishing
industry and the industry of journalism
and we here of course you know depending
on who talks about it the death-knell
being sounded for any one of these
industries on the one hand if you talk
to people on the East Coast and the
Phoenix cry rising from the ashes on the
west coast of the reinvention of these
industries well I come to you tonight
and wonder whether we might engage in
the similar kind of Geographic arbitrage
and figure out here together whether
there are ways that we can re-engineer
our political institutions in the same
way that we are thinking about this in
the guard to our institutions and
political and social and economic life
so we did a small experiment along these
lines with a project that would call
peer to patent but I want to tell you
about for a minute and then bring you up
to date on what we're doing in the Obama
administration to do this on a more
widespread scale so EO Wilson once said
the world is full of amateurs gifted
amateurs devoted amateurs you can pick
almost any group that is any kind of
intrinsic interest in it from
Bagon flies to pill bugs to orb-weaving
spiders anybody can pick up information
in interesting places find new species
to rediscover what was thought to be a
vanished species or some new biological
fact about a species already known and
if we seize upon this truth that out
there there is everywhere there is an
expert in something whether it's
expertise that is derived through
experience or through learning or
through enthusiasm that each of us is an
expert in something and we are
increasingly using it that expertise
whether it's to make youtube videos and
put them online
or get involved in distributed coding
projects or participate in new ways in
our social life that we might actually
take advantage of in our political life
so the idea behind peer to patent was to
take this problem of bureaucratic
slowdown and inefficiency in the Patent
Office and to marry to this idea of
self-selected expertise and create a
process by which people could volunteer
self-selected to work together not as
individuals merely sending information
to the government but work together in
teams and groups to help discover
information that would help an examiner
decide whether a patent truly deserves a
20 year grant of monopoly rights the
patent is it truly non-obvious and novel
as the law requires and so by creating a
software interface and a software system
that would allow groups of people to
self-select to come together to review
each other's work so again in groups not
simply as individuals and thereby to
take some of the burden off the already
beleaguered government examiner by using
visual interfaces and the screen to help
reflect back to and explain to people
clearly what is it that they need to do
how do they do up the tasks of actually
examining a patent we were able to set
up a project not at a remove from
government but together with government
the first institutionalized social
network in the federal government to
actually participate in the work of
decision-making that would actually
allow us to connect a network to an
institution to help it improve the way
it works now this is not despite you
know people I have a book alcohol wiki
government and the word wiki is fun and
easy to say
but it's not in fact a purely Wicca fide
process where there's a free-for-all
where anybody can type and write
whatever they want of course Wikipedia
doesn't work this way any either
but it marries the crowdsourcing of
scientific expertise with the
institutionalized legal decision making
by a patent examiner to arrive at a
decision so we get the software
engineers and the garage enthusiasts
from all over the country saying ah let
me take a look at that invention have I
seen anything like that before and we
marry that to the knowledge of the legal
rules of the patent system that the
examiner has to arrive hopefully faster
and better at a decision now this
process which began as a pilot program
over two years is in the process of
being transformed into an
institutionalized process of the Patent
Office to actually bring an in-house as
as the way the patent office will work
and so what we see here is the
opportunity I think to rethink not only
our democratic institutions but our
democratic theory and let me pause for a
moment to say why I think that this is
actually a change over the way that
we've talked about even participatory
democracy before so a lot of people with
the advent of technology said great we
will move to a system of direct
democracy push-button voting where we
can actually have everybody voting in
real time directly on making decisions
but we know that that of course is not a
sufficiently complex as a way of working
I mean it's nice you know when my
students can push a clicker and say
faster and slower or louder or I don't
understand but in the complex world of
political decision making direct
democracy is not necessarily the best
way to make decisions on the basis of
information and good science on the
other hand there's the world really of
deliberative democracy which has long
been held up as the great ideal to which
we should expire we're neighbors talk to
one another in civic and civilized
discourse but the problem with
deliberative democracy and this is in
part the artifact of our old
technological era is that it puts all
the emphasis on talk rather than on
action so whereas it's very nice to come
together with one's neighbors and debate
the issues of the day if what we really
have to do is make change happen and
take action we have to think in fact
about the inputs not about how we talk
together but the outputs how do we
actually take action together how do we
solve problems how do we get stuff done
and that is what I would term are
referred to as collaborative democracy
the world of peer to patent where we
actually are marrying up the work of the
crowd the work of the network with that
of the institution that allows us to an
extent and I think this is a midway
point on a longer-term historical
trajectory which I'll talk about in a
minute of devolving power downward of
devolving power outward from our
representative institutions at the
center that are supposed to represent us
but increasingly are disconnected from
us to a much more decentralized world of
power where the groups to which we can
join and to which we belong and that's
the exciting thing about the online life
is that now we can choose from among
thousands of different associations to
which we want to contribute our time and
our money and our attention whether for
a short term or for longer term that we
can get involved in in order to make
change happen to do stuff in the world a
kind of cosmopolitan pluralism if you
will that the internet enables a new
kind of equality of power that really
allows us now to think about how we can
re-engineer our institutions not simply
for the sake of talk but as a means to
an end of actually achieving things in
the world better faster and in new and
creative ways to attract and attack the
complex problems that really we confront
and at the basis of this is really the
notion which is cut which is I think
something that we all essentially
intuitively realize and know and which
has been supported by a great deal of
empirical research by folks like the
group brain project at Harvard
Stephen kosslyn and Richard Hackman the
idea that when we come together when we
share our diverse expertise we are
stronger than when we work alone and for
so long our systems of political
participation particularly in government
have always revolved around the
individual the individual vote the
individual comment on a regulatory
rulemaking but are so limited in the way
that we have turned to looking at groups
of people and organizations of people to
really get involved in helping us
to do our jobs better and so this is a
world that we're seeing lots of this
concept that is now emerging
increasingly in our social life but not
yet in our political life to the same
extent so if we look at very recently to
talk about something that's in the news
just in the last few weeks in response
to Haiti in response to Chile the crisis
camps that have sprung up groups of
people that are getting together to hold
hackathons if you will in support of
creating software that will help for
disaster relief and recovery so mission
46:36
the emergency reporting service that
allowed anyone in Haiti with a cell
phone to text the number 46:36 with a
message a geo coded message that would
help identify where that person actually
was and that relied that on teams of
volunteers to translate those messages
from Creole into English and to help
actually identify again where people
were so that actually combined the
concept of crowdsourcing lots of
distributed volunteers with then micro
work specific tasks that people would
need to do in order to solve the
tremendous problem of disaster relief
and recovery this is now growing into a
whole movement that's come to be called
crisis Commons not just crisis camps
that take place on weekends but that now
is I think going forward over time that
will become an institutionalized org an
organized effort at developing better
software and tools and better again
nation of volunteers to help with
disaster relief and recovery and we got
this really really well in the campaign
we all knew about this when we got
involved and engaged whether it was for
Obama or whether it was for McCain we
understood what it meant to do this kind
of distributed work so we knew what it
meant in fact to then to phone bank or
to get someone to drive to the polls or
to donate money or to take on a task
that would allow us to participate
toward the common end of electing the
candidate of our choice I bet that many
people in the audience here were in some
way involved in Silicon Valley for Obama
which as we all know was not a campaign
office set up by the central apparatus
in Chicago but was spontaneously created
by volunteers in the South Bay who
galvanized
tens of thousands of volunteers
to actually get involved in and building
the tools and doing the phone banking
and doing the work to actually help to
support the campaign and became in fact
part of the election apparatus if you
will but we grew up spontaneously from
outside and you know Obama himself has
talked about this he writes about this
in the audacity of hope' when he talks
about his visit to Google and he talks
about the mesmerizing image more organic
than mechanical he says if I were
glimpsing the early stages of some
accelerating evolutionary process in
which all the boundaries between men
nationality race religion wealth were
rendered invisible and irrelevant so the
physicists in Cambridge the bond trader
in Tokyo the student in a remote Indian
village and the manager of a Mexico City
department store were drawn into a
single constant thrumming conversation
time and space giving way to a world
spun entirely of light a very poetical
rendition of that sense that we have
that oceanic feeling of being part of
the network that allows us to bring
about this kind of change so the
question is how do we take this
change.org if you will what we all know
from our civic life and there are tens
of examples and this is bringing coals
to Newcastle to talk about this in the
Bay Area all of these examples come from
here or most of them many of them but
the question is how do we import this
how do I take this back with me to
Washington how do we import this into a
vision of reshaping our institutions so
that they go from looking like this to
looking like that so there are some
examples so DARPA turns around to
celebrate the growth of the Internet
they run this competition which many of
you may have heard about to say woo can
identify the fastest where these 10
balloons end up these are the release of
the ten balloons and MIT runs this
phenomenal crowdsourcing project that
essentially not unlike other
incentive-based of social networking
schemes Awards allows people who get
help from people in their social network
identifying where the balloons are to
share the reward money with them and in
9 hours using simple off-the-shelf
social network
can commercially-available Facebook etc
social networking technologies to
identify where the ten balloons actually
work and you know in fact this is this
cut this example the idea of using teams
and relying on teams and doing this wing
collaboration with the government
institution is the exciting I think new
prospect of where we can go going
forward using technology to reinforce
and enable the ability of people to work
in groups and to work effectively in
groups to self organize themselves in
ways that we could only do a few years
ago if we work together face to face we
can now marry this ability of the
network to the actual work of the
institution so we have to think about
the process of institutional reinvention
and Alexis de Tocqueville who came and
observed of course American life now not
not that long ago anymore
where are we in time a while ago he
writes in his recollections I am tempted
to believe that what we call necessary
institutions are often no more than
institutions to which we have grown
accustomed and that in matters of social
Constitution the field of possibilities
is much more extensive than men living
in their various societies are ready to
imagine and of course that's the case
those of us who live within the status
quo have a very hard time re-engineering
from within and yet if we want to think
about the prospects for peaceful
evolution rather than bloody revolution
we have to think about how we begin to
embark on the path of the long now of
the re-engineering of our institutions
in this peaceful way that will allow us
however to experience change at scale
and so I want to tell you a little bit
about how we are embarking on this
process of institutional redesign now in
the first year of the Obama
administration it is not the concept of
the thousand flowers blooming like
free-for-all direct Democratic let's do
all of government by wiki nor is it the
command-and-control approach that we
have been used to in our representative
institutions which are nonetheless
entirely have been command and control
in the way that they work and yet there
is instead the notion of a kind of
focused collab
raishin and organized collaboration that
it's again I think the interim point on
this pathway towards re-engineering of
our democratic institutions and this is
an idea that I think has had a lot of
compelling resonance not just within
government and without but the idea of a
cultural change and has been picked up
by so many people all of whom are
outside government now picked up after
the president issued his first a
memorandum the very first action of the
president took and I think that has
significance that it was the very first
thing that he did was to sign this
executive memorandum on transparency and
open government on his first day in
office to use the bully pulpit and the
tremendous star power of his presidency
especially to say we are going to change
the way that our institutions function
according to three core values
transparency participation and
collaboration in other words we're going
to use openness as a mantra to drive the
way that we do business not is
essentially a new thing not as a
vertical but as a horizontal as the
social operating layer of the way that
our institutions work we are actually
going to institute a policy process that
began with this memorandum and had
another culminating point on December
8th when we issued the directive on open
government to say that we are going to
try to move all of our political
institutions towards more open and
collaborative towards more networked
ways of working so this is a tough
question and we can talk and I hope that
we do about what it means to try to
re-engineer an institution as big as the
American government from within within a
manageable amount of time I know that
there's the long net perspective which
says we could just wait it out until all
the institutions crumble and maybe in a
thousand years it'll all look different
but I'm too impatient for that and you
know so I am the short now thinker in
that sense and we have to try to Mary
the sense of enthusiasm and action and
doing things in the here and now with a
long-term vision of what it means to
actually have you know what it actually
means to have institutions that act in a
long-term responsible way by creating
the institutions catalyzing the change
that will make that possible so every
agency has now been tasked with the idea
of coming up with its own open
government plan it is not a top-down
stricture or Mae
except insofar as to say every agency
from the bottom up must come up with its
own plan for how to re-engineer that it
the way that it works how do we take
essentially the strategic goals of the
agency the strategic goals of all the
actors within the executive branch of
government and change the way that they
happen how do we get everybody to start
thinking about what can you do to try to
make change happen informed by these
values now part of the way that we do
that is of course with people people and
charismatic leadership is incredibly
important and that starts with President
Obama himself and it starts with the
creation of new roles like a chief
technology officer Aneesh Chopra or a
chief federal chief information officer
like Vivek Kundra who's here in San was
here in San Francisco yesterday together
with Gavin Newsom unveiling the new open
3-1-1 initiative that Miss um of you may
have seen in the news or I'll just pick
out one other person Todd Park who some
of you may know also from the West Coast
the co-founder of Athena health who now
is the CTO the new innovation head of
Health and Human Services it's the
creation of these new roles that helps
to actually spread the message of
cultural change and shift and it's
extremely important that in addition to
that day one Memorandum of transparency
participation and collaboration that
those same values and those same words
that went into writing that memorandum
actually were also used to help
interview cabinet secretaries and senior
leaders and political appointees within
the government before they were chosen
to ensure that people were coming on
board who ascribed to and believed in
and this concept of institutional change
and innovation of institutional Rd that
we should turn upon ourselves to improve
the way that our institutions work we
also do this of course we have to do it
through projects enabled by the
technical technology platforms that
allow us to do these projects at scale
across the federal government and in
part we have to do it through real work
that allows us to take the genie out of
the bottle in order that we can't put it
back in because it's one thing to
articulate policies to have noble words
and grand statements about the
importance of openness and transparency
but we all know that from administration
to administration these policies have
changed we have had one policy under
Clinton
reverse then under Bush reverse then
under Obama of course that makes the
default rule to be one of openness a
default rule more sweeping than ever
before but nonetheless we have to back
up the words and the commitment to
transparency which actual work that
we're doing so the commitment to
transparency in the way we're bringing
about changes by opening the doors and
opening the data of government making
unprecedent openness the default but
also doing things like posting all the
visitor logs from the White House
posting up online who comes and goes for
the first time ever so that you can see
and analyze in fact who comes to visit
me and who comes to visit other people
in the White House too so we know that
there are no secret energy meetings
going on but in fact those are happening
out in the open that has by the way a
very salutary effect on the way that we
work because we then come to think about
if I'm meeting with Group X on one side
of the political spectrum
I maybe should now think about that I
meet need to meet with a group of group
Y on the other side of the political
spectrum in order to make sure that I'm
hearing all views and getting adequate
representation in the expertise which
we're confronting it also involves
projects like projects like launching
recovery gov that are creating
unprecedented transparency in the way
that we spend our money posting the
salaries of White House staff work like
PO the fee three point nine million
streams of the health care summit that
took place last week and so there is
this the way in which by creating the
technical platforms and pushing the
release of the data onto platforms like
data.gov and then the spin-off platforms
that data.gov is spawning whether on the
state or local level that are actually
engendering and ensuring the data
becomes truly transparent and open
data.gov since its inception a few
months ago has already had 60 over 64
million hits to the site so to those who
would ask who actually wants raw
government data while 64 million people
seem to want raw government data and
when it comes to things like the IT
dashboard or usaspending.gov or I this
is IT usaspending.gov that tracks 76
billion dollars of IT spending in
government eight
9 million people seem to want to see
this data that then in turn allows the
kind of data jamming or culture jamming
if you will where people take the data
and mash it up and use it for other
purposes
which I'll talk a little bit more about
but just last week because we made
available the stream of the video of the
health care summit the sunlight
foundation was able to turn around and
give readers and viewers then not only
the video but the video annotated by who
what campaign contributions are being
given to the person who's speaking
during the summit and it was phenomenal
the number of views that they got and as
one as one critic put it the sunlight
foundation of media event that took
place was quote a smack down to CNN in
terms of the actual true you know effect
on transparency because they let the
data do the talking and provide an
all-too the talking heads on the cable
news shows or even the pot or even the
talking politicians on c-span by giving
people the raw data the chance to make
up their minds for themselves as it
related to the health care summit so
when even you take this raw material
when you can remix it and reuse it to do
interesting things with it becomes an ax
power 'fl powerful social tool so this
goal of data transparency and ensuring
that all agencies now under the open
government directive must inventory
their data decide which data to put up
first online and have to release what we
term high-value data are actually
getting out there information that is
either for example information that is
about government spending so that helped
us to reduce waste fraud and abuse by
putting out information about how
government money is being spent and we
use specifically the recovery.gov
process the spending and the tracking of
spending of recovery money as a way to
bootstrap data tracking down to the
state and local level let me tell you
it's a very hard process because that
data is kept in very different ways
sometimes you know in fancy coded XML
sometimes in Excel spreadsheets
sometimes in a shoebox at the local
level and so trying to track that data
is hard but we're starting the process
using this as a mechanism for actually
tracking how we spend money as a way of
opening up
ensuring the government institutions are
more efficient but high-value data is
more than just government data that
helps promote government accountability
it's also data that helps us to achieve
the core mission of a given agency and
so for example the USDA has released a
data set about nutritional nutritional
data set about the nutritional
information caloric values on the top on
the major foods that we eat what this
does it doesn't help us know how much
money the USDA spends but what it does
help us to do is to launch an initiative
with foundations with corporations to
create a game that helps young people
make healthier eating decisions or that
allows then volunteer developers to mash
up that data and create cool iPhone
applications or new people to start
businesses that might generate economic
value so it's high value data because it
achieves a core mission in this case
reducing childhood obesity that has been
one of the centerpieces not only the
president but of the first lady's agenda
that is a picture of a yam by the way if
you're wondering what that is in the
White House garden which I've had the
privilege speaking of crowdsourcing you
can volunteer to weed the White House
garden which I have done I have
accidentally sat on the president's
lettuce and there is a picture of me
doing this somewhere but that is one of
the high points of my political service
thus far and I'm not I'm not really
joking because if you're a gardener this
is the most beautiful garden you have
ever seen there's not a weed in sight
because of all of us crowd-sourced
volunteers pulling the weeds out there
but the point is the transparency and
the release of raw data helps to drive
then a culture of participation of
loving that data of doing things with it
that allow us to actually generate real
value and meaning in people's lives so
the participation has had of course new
forms that of course will seem
completely you know almost standard and
rote by the standards of Silicon Valley
but you have to understand that when we
came in and created the White House open
government initiative this was the first
blog that took comments not that there
really is a blog without comments but
this is the first commenting site that
we ever had on a White House website the
first blog in government only began in
2008
from of all places the TSA so things
that we take for granted here as totally
standard and we'll I think in another
few months take for granted as totally
standard even within government has for
such a long time not at all been the
case so the president's interactive
YouTube question time that he did a few
weeks ago the Department of Labor
rolling out its regulatory agenda for
example or its budget using web chat and
you would say geez Department of Labor's
regulatory agenda you know probably 99%
of people in the audience here thinks
news but 1% of people in this audience
and that's the notion of distributed
expertise and enthusiasm think this is
fantastic
and in fact 1,500 live participants
watched the budget rollout and 6,000
people have since watched the videos
archived but not live and that's
compared to 100 or 200 people who could
participate in these meetings live when
they took place in a room in Washington
previously and so in fact if we look at
things for example like NASA think about
NASA Ames Research Center which is only
about 35 miles south of here in Silicon
Valley so what NASA has done is NASA has
really embraced this concept of citizen
participation and coined the term
participatory exploration space
exploration so they have been convening
gatherings of Silicon Valley
professionals and NASA experts to
discuss how to use new tools and to
create community as a way of building
participation and they began employing
crowdsourcing methodologies and
advocating for more programs that will
engage the public and this year in their
FY L fiscal year 11 budget have received
the modest amount but it's an amount
nonetheless of five million dollars to
spend on their new participatory
exploration office um and this is
exciting because it really creates it
highlights the opportunities that exist
for people to work together again to
really achieve goals that happens when
you marry participants parents in
participation so this is just one of
again thousand examples that I could
give you and I've stolen here a phrase
that Stuart used earlier in the day with
me the notion of ensuring that their
note when we put the data out there and
let
people look at it they find the gaps
they find the Dragons they find the
missing spaces they see the patterns and
they see the consequences of that data
but it's and they're able to make the
visualizations to make the games to make
the iPhone apps that actually turns
transparency raw data and information
into useful knowledge and when we have
that then in turn we can create more
informed processes of participation in
policymaking so actually involving
people in government decision-making so
when we created the White House open
government initiative the first thing we
did was to open up the question what
should our open government policy be to
the American people Ewing using a series
of online tools and techniques the
Office of Information and regulatory
affairs within the Office of Management
and Budget has created now a regulatory
dashboard which I really commend to you
to go look at it's in brand new and it's
in its first instance and iteration but
that's trying to put out information
about how government maker makes
regulations unless we think that
legislation is where the action is at we
pass about 400 pieces of legislation a
year we're making between 4,000 and
8,000 rules every year it's the
executive branch agencies that's where a
lot of the detailed work of implementing
regulate of implementing legislation
actually takes place so it's these
efforts of actually creating open
policymaking forums the Office of
Science and Technology Policy has for
the last several weeks run a forum to
ask what should our policy actually be
on public access to government-funded
research we've run a forum on web
cookies that's now used public input to
help decide what our policy should be on
the use of cookies on government
websites it's the it's all this whole
series and I could go on of new open
policymaking initiatives that are being
spawned and what with the release of the
open government directive one of the
things that it is created is that every
single government agency in fact now has
turned around to create its own open
government webpage so you can go to
epa.gov slash open or do t gov slash
open and there you can actually provide
input on the open government plan so
every agency is running an idea scale
they're using a product called idea
scale which is
ideation platform a brainstorming
platform to actually generate ideas for
how to make the agency more open the
citizen engagement tool has been live
for about 25 days and I say I have to
confess I don't think we've done a good
enough job of letting people know that
the opportunity exists this is the I
think the most historic opportunity it
is government wide open participation in
policymaking we do have about 1,200
ideas that have been posted across the
federal government about how to become
more open and more participatory but we
need more and we need everybody whatever
their issue of interest to come in and
say I care about seeing this data set
released or here is how I think the
agency should be more participatory or
here are ways in which we could be more
collaborative or just to get involved
because it's only by getting involved
that the message will go and get to
these institutions that we want
participation that we want transparency
that it matters to people and that if we
build it they will in fact come if we
build the open institutions people will
come and get involved and participate so
just give you another example from NASA
again from from Ames here is in the NASA
website under the on their IdeaScale
site someone posted the idea the top
idea there was for NASA sponsored space
themed barcamps very West Coast idea and
the ideas that people posted can be
commented on by other users and so
someone put in the comment field that in
fact there is the first space themed bar
Camp was going to be taking place in
last weekend in San Diego called space
up I don't know if anybody was there
anybody attend space up well NASA saw
the posting and they saw the comment and
they got on a plane and they went out to
San Diego and they sponsored the event
and they showed up and they participated
in the weekend and work with the
community of interest in a developing
the ideas that then came out of space up
now space up would have happened whether
NASA showed up or participated or not
but because there was this real
collaboration this true participation
between the institution and the network
the wonderful things emerge and that
again the community of practice was
really fostered one of the ways we're
doing this again is by enabling
participation through platforms so
data.gov is how
to ensure that when agencies want to put
up their data they have a place to put
it when you want to find data you have a
place to go to search for it well the
government the government Services
Administration the General Services
Administration excuse me GSA which
provides pens and pencils and cars and
buildings to the federal government also
provide software tools and they have
negotiated now 165 new so-called
government friendly in other words they
have the requisite privacy provisions
and accessibility provisions new social
media platforms and that's just since
November and so this allows any agency
that wants to use Facebook or YouTube or
Google Analytics or social text or Bing
Search API to then just essentially pull
it off of Apps gov so if you're out
there and you're a developer or you're
an entrepreneur and you have a tool
whether free or fee submit it to Apps
gov it's by the way a lot faster than
going through a traditional procurement
and it makes it available to anyone in
government who wants to use it and I
highly recommend combining it then with
a video a screencast that actually shows
people how and why they should use your
tool but we desperately need access to
the tools and technologies that will
allow us to do more and better
participation so finally the last prong
of the agenda is collaboration
transparency fairly obvious
participation collaboration
intentionally having a third prong to
the agenda it's not the same as
participation because it's not just
about how you get involved in government
but how in fact government can in turn
push out problems and challenges and
ideas to people and let them and invite
them to engage in new ways than we've
ever done before and so that's the
notion both of connecting government
institutions to government institutions
so you heard about this open three one
one project that launched yesterday
where San Francisco has really been at
the forefront and together
collaboratively with the White House and
the federal government and creating a
community of state and local government
organizations that are actually involved
in sharing code and sharing tools and
working together to create common data
standards that will allow for the
development of new and better software
applications and software services like
3-1-1 services that can be adopted then
and spread to any city
so the
citizens get better services like 300
across the nation it's also a way to
connect government employees to one
another to again solve problems more
effectively so you may or may not know
that now the army writes its field
manual using wiki media and then in fact
not URI but all soldiers in fact can
participate in and hundreds are doing so
to write the Army Field Manual of
practice so that the people who actually
know are helping to write the rules of
the road for people in the military and
just last week the Department of Defense
in fact unveiled its new social media
policy going further frankly than the
civilian agency is that allowing the use
of any kind of social media within
limits and that's leading of course -
now the creation of this Apps for
Democracy effort of scuse me the apps
for army or a for a project
another apps development challenge that
the Army itself is running to develop
skills excuse me to foster the
development of software skills and
programming skills but to develop
applications and tools that are actually
useful to people in the military the
veterans benefit administration and the
VA have actually been at the forefront
of this idea of collaboratively
connecting employees to employees using
a tool called kindling they've been
running a competition initially to
invite employees to come up with ideas
for how to reduce the backlog of
veterans benefits claims and in the
first week 7,000 out of 19,000 employees
7,000 of them participated in submitting
ideas 3000 ideas suggested in the first
month of the competition ideas for
example like the Pittsburgh VA regional
office that suggested the idea that we
could actually lessen the backlog if
veterans took a form with them when they
went to the doctor a standard form that
would allow standardized medical
questionnaire that could be completed by
the treating physician that would then
facilitate and streamline the process of
applying for benefits so that the
diagnosis and treatment by the physician
didn't in then in turn have to be
translated into another form and another
piece of paperwork and that was so
successful this process that now the
ei has launched another similar crowd
ideation brainstorming process if you
will to try to crowdsource the how the
VA can actually improve its health IT
and healthcare IT related systems within
the VA so again this idea is really
taking off and there now has been
created in government and ideation
community of practice all the agencies
who are interested in running
brainstorming initiatives the first
meeting that we ran purely informal
totally voluntary pouring rain on the
day that we held it 60 people show up
from 30 agencies and that's all people
who are about to start want to start
want to know how to do this kind of open
collaborative brainstorming Danny Hillis
who of course is part of the one of the
founding members of long now is the
creator of a tool called Aristotle
Aristotle that's now being deployed
across the Defense Department it's
essentially Facebook for scientists and
technologists across the DoD to connect
them to one another so as to hear the
sort of progenitor of the project within
the Navy who has been spearheading the
implementation tells me you know that
instead of actually discovering after
the fact that the guy at the next desk
to you has the expertise that you need
to figure out how to solve the problem
of dust getting into the helicopter
blades of the that's that's bringing
down helicopters in Afghanistan and so
only discover after the fact that the
guy the next desk actually flew those
helicopters for nine years before he
held that desk job when you discover
that after the fact there's something
wrong that you should be able to know
that before the fact which is why
Aristotle is being used now across the
DoD to connect SNT professionals but we
need far more of these kinds of expert
tools expert networking tools to allow
us to do our job better collaboration
like the Federal Regulations 2.0 project
which is an example of connecting public
to private so not just government to
government and government employees but
public to private so that when the
National Archives and Records
Administration decides that it will take
the Federal Register the newspaper of
our democracy the newspaper that
essentially records the actions of the
federal government every single day
something it used to sell for $17,000
per subscription
and decides that we will give it away
because this is data that belongs to the
American people and is a national public
asset and we shouldn't be selling it
data that has been created with your
taxpayer dollars with my dollars instead
we release this and publish it what
happens well what happens is the folks
from gulf pulse who I think are here in
the audience here on the west coast are
you here there they are
or public resource who also come here
from Sebastopol turn around and rebuild
oh there we go a fan a fan of a fan of
Carl Melvin in the front row turn around
and recreate this this is what the
Federal Register looks like and turn it
into this so they create this is one
made by Princeton
there's gulf pulse at the top that
actually allows you to search rules and
regs by geography so show me the rules
that apply only to me in Indiana or the
Fed thread project which allows me to
annotate and have a conversation about
what's going on in government something
that we absolutely can't do with this or
the this project the public resource
project that actually creates hyperlinks
within the documents so that when a rule
references another rule or a piece of
legislation I can actually understand
the context for something that I'm
looking at these projects created in one
week after the release of the data set
so some of them had been worked on up
until then but the change that we could
make happen so quickly through
public/private collaboration or in turn
not by connecting public and private but
by getting out of the way and connecting
citizens to one another endorsing and
inspiring and talking about and
celebrating a project like National Lab
day everybody here I'm sure remembers
net day yes
so think net day for school science labs
and when this project launched and again
a project that from start to start to
launch was a matter of weeks months at
most had signed up organizations
representing 2 million members engineers
scientists and technologists who
volunteering to go into America's
schools to do hands-on learning with our
high school and middle school students
to ensure that we are not last in
science but first or a project like
broadband match
dot-gov that the NTIA has set up to
allow applicants for 7.2 billion dollars
in broadband grant funds to find one
another it's a kind of match.com for
grant applicants to say I'm a small
grantee and you're a big grantee let's
get together and write a good
application and so this idea of helping
to connect citizens to citizens is one
of the I think the most important things
that we can and are trying to do to move
the culture shift forward so let me just
close by saying a little bit finally
about how what we how we've done this
and and where we go from here
people have to know what's being asked
of them that's I think what's in common
to all of these projects is the better
job that we can do and we have a long
way to go to learn how to do that of
articulating the problem articulating
the question and then explaining to
people what we need their help with and
how to do it the easier it will be for
people to get involved and to and to
participate in the same way than the
campaign we understood what it meant to
phonebank or to drive someone to the
polls or to get out the vote or to
donate money
we now need similarly to chunk the
questions to chunk the work so that
people in the process of governance can
get involved in policymaking processes
not just in elections now but in
actually how we make decisions on an
ongoing basis to affect this kind of
change and as I alluded to before I
think that visualization and the use of
the interface we could have a whole
other long now presentation about the
way that the visual interface is
powerful and helping us to do this so
one of the simple things that we've done
is to set up on the White House website
something called the open government
innovations gallery in which we post
cool ideas cool projects that are going
on in government as a way to inspire
other people to follow the lead so again
TSA the first entity to create what they
called idea Factory which was one of
these idea generation tools and you'll
see an example here of the this is a the
tool that they've created to allow their
employees to make suggestions for how to
improve the functioning of airport
security then we could take a poll about
whether we think this is working or not
I think it actually is here was an idea
posted for a respect
divesting bins and I don't know if you
can read if you can read the small print
but I'll let you guess what that
actually refers to in terms of security
at the airport but think grandma's ashes
and this is this system which is not
only about generating ideas but then
taking money and investing the ideas
that in that employees suggests is now
as I've talked about spreading all
across the government but what we're
doing is the way it's spreading is by
people being able to see what other
people are doing and emulate their
example share code share best practices
and share knowledge so this only works
though if you if we all get involved if
we all help if you adopt a data set so
you know it's like adopt a highway adopt
a data set find some data to love to
mash up to visualize to create an iPhone
app from to build a tool around to build
a business with we need people to use
the data to tell us what data needs to
be released because frankly the
government sits on huge amounts of
information and we can't release it all
at once
we're committed though to making it
openly available in downloadable open
formats online in as real time as we can
do it but we need your help with
prioritize do first and what we do
second and so we need your ideas for
what to do in terms of data how to save
money how to green the government had a
better encourage and facilitate citizen
engagement and participation and I have
facilitate the kind of collaboration
that we've talked about so I think what
we're talking about here is not the
world of participation that we've known
it in other words a world of voting
where everybody does the same thing come
November election time but where you may
want to love a data set from the EPA and
I might want to help the Department of
Transportation with how it does citizen
engagement and a third person wants to
participate in reviewing a patent
application we don't all want to do the
same thing but the equality of
opportunity is what's important by
creating and proliferating lots of
different opportunities for engagement
driven by transparency and availability
of raw data that we can take advantage
of so that everybody has a way to get
involved in some
thing that feeds and inspires their
passion their expertise and their
enthusiasm and what's really going on
here I think is it's just an interim
step it's a big and long interim step to
remake and overhaul the way that our
federal government works to create these
kinds of open institutions but it is
only an interim step on I think a much
longer evolutionary trajectory that
really will devolve power downward to us
and to the associations and
organizations and groups of which we are
a part in radically new ways that in a
long time from now won't look like the
representative of government the
representative government we know today
but will come to look like something
very different when more federal
government institutions start to
collaborate with the gov pulses and the
Fed threads of the world or to support
the National Lab Day initiatives or that
work with a hundred different companies
on developing commitments to investing
in STEM education science technology
engineering and math this is all then
the future that the net is enabling of
allowing us to create increasingly
powerful purpose of groups groups that
can come up with new ideas sometimes
rewarded with prizes or other types of
incentives that help us to solve
problems in new ways and so technology
is increasingly enabling ordinary people
now to come together across distances to
do these things to do these increasingly
important work whether on a local level
or now at scale on a national level to
get involved in bringing their
collective wisdom to bear and bringing
their collective talent to bear to
actually change the way that we work and
this is fundamentally as the political
philosopher Hannah Arendt wrote it's
fundamentally about power because power
she said corresponds to the human
ability not just to act but to act in
concert powers never the property of an
individual it belongs to a group and
remains in existence only so long as the
group keeps together so when we set our
minds to something and we work in
concert to make it happen we are very
powerful and working together we can
accomplish things that we cannot do
alone
and that means that implies that our
political institutions have to evolve to
recognize this new reality of power have
to evolve to enable us to work together
to help us collectively to solve the
increasingly complex problems that we
face but in turn we have to step up to
the task we have to demand this of our
institutions we have to demand it of
ourselves so that and we have to get
involved and we have to take action and
the opportunity exists now like it never
has before with an administration that
is a hundred and fifty percent committed
to an agenda of openness of transparency
of participation of collaboration of
creating this concept of recognizing the
power and the intelligence and the
expertise of individuals of trusting the
American public and of as the president
says bringing all hands on deck to the
problems that we face today so with that
let me stop and invite discussion and
it's been really a pleasure to have an
opportunity to talk to you today about
what we're trying to do here to
re-engineer reinvent our government and
over the long term I think and hope
reinvent our democracy as we know it
today thank you
over there let's go over the stools
you're not allowed to sell your book
outside I understand so I have to say
that Beth is a great book called wiki
government and I think it's okay if I
ask you and you say what's in it that
doesn't violate any government
regulation on the spot
I can't say no so wiki government is a
wiki government is a book that covers a
lot of the ideas that have gone into
this open government initiative and it
really covers both this question of how
we from a legal and policy perspective
re-engineer our institutions but also
technologically what it means to take
advantage of the visual interface how do
we design the tools so it's a book that
both covers the technical side if you
will the aesthetic side and the legal
and policy side of how we actually think
about reinventing our institutions as
institutions of collaborative democracy
so in fact I've had the dubious
distinction or misfortune depending on
how you look at it to have written the
book and then taking the job now to
implement the ideas in the book so
everywhere in the book it says the
government should do that and now I'm
going oh god now that's my problem so
it's a it's a it's a wonderful and
daunting problem to have remember the
office of Technology Assessment that
Congress used to have 94 and one of the
first things that Newt Gingrich did I
think was erased that from existence I
realize this is not something the
administration can do directly but is
their hope of getting Congress back with
its own ability to pay attention to
what's going on with technology with
something like the OTA well tell you
there two to two parts of that one is I
think this president surely in contrast
the last eight years but I think more
than any president you know in 50 years
if ever is so committed to science is so
committed to the importance of science
education and to an innovation agenda to
the to the to this country he has you
know
we have increased our budgets for
science Rd we have invested in STEM
education you may know that the
Department of Education has a race to
the top fund this competitive grant fund
for the states that the one preference
that it gives is to states that actually
have a science education component to
their applications so I would like to
think that by example we set an agenda I
think for the importance of science and
of course the appointment of stellar
scientists like Steven Chu like John
holder into the roles of they're in
really sends a signal
I hope about the importance of good
quality science and what we do but what
I would also add to that is our in our
efforts to try to create greater expert
networking things like the Aristotle
project that connect SNT professionals
across the DoD and now efforts to do
similar things in the civilian agencies
efforts to look at how do we actually
connect with networks of scientists and
experts outside of government as well as
I think also based on a recognition that
science matters and that we need to have
that kind of participatory assessment
function that the OTA gave us we need we
can reinvent an era of networks you know
on steroids if you will that will allow
us to get better scientific expertise
into the way that we make decisions you
know better than even the OTA so I hope
that that's something we can do across
branches but we have to start at least
with our own shop that's right from
Laura Erickson where are you this
question given that the defense budget
makes up nearly half of the total budget
how does the concept and practice apply
to DoD since the outlays for national
security have such a large impact on
everything else this is a paramount
importance for an individual or groups
political life absolutely well it's why
I think one of you know the the data.gov
project the platform to enable the
release of government data and to make
it more searchable and accessible is a
platform that's been created across the
CIO community in government including by
the DoD CIO Dave Winer Green has been an
active part of that team and it's why
the DIA the DoD and the both the defense
and the intelligence agencies have been
actively involved in the project from
the beginning because we have to of
course in everything that we do when we
talk about open government we do of
course have to balance that with the
demands of national security
also of personal privacy is key but I
think no one in many ways has been at
the forefront more and you may perhaps
find this ironic is in many ways the
Defense Department with the release of
it social media policy with the launch
of something like Aristotle it's the
furthest ahead in the use of social
networking and social media in many
respects now issues of other kinds of
transparency and whatnot may be further
behind for some people's liking and
that's where again we sort of have to
balance the demands of national security
against the demands of transparency to
ensure that we're doing transparency in
smart ways but I think you know the
Defense Department has really been arm
in arm with many of these initiatives
moving forward they also have an open
government page so if there are things
you want to see and I'm sure there's a
long list that's the place to say we
want these datasets we want to see
engagement this way and here's how we
want people to get you know we want to
create more openness in the DoD that's
another kind of managerial question from
Adrienne looks like Cottard how are the
various bureaucracies responding already
taking the long view and how is the data
vetted and our the bureau's held
accountable on all this Oh big question
how people are responding so the culture
shift is of course you know it's a hard
it'll be an interesting thing to look
back and reflect on how this has worked
in different agencies and we've been
talking about what's the documentation
process for even just filming and
telling the stories of how some of this
change has taken place which i think is
a really interesting journalistic
opportunity and some agencies are
further along than others so partly with
all that we're doing is unleashing and
opening up opportunities for innovators
that have long sat within these
organizations and institutions so it's
not just short term political leadership
that's creating it but it's unleashing
the power of the people who've been
there for the long haul in the long term
who know the best in many cases how to
fix what's broken and so it's unleashing
those people and their enthusiasm and
their ideas that's I think been the most
rewarding and it's so much fun to talk
to people who say gee I've been waiting
10 years to do X
or I've so long wanted to do why so
there is a lot of receptivity I think to
this process of change particularly
where again it's sort of balancing that
short-term burst of enthusiasm with what
can we do today to make change happen
against that kind of longer-term vision
but it's also hard there's a lot of
institutionalized resistance to the
notion of people have been told for a
long time
data shouldn't be open or free and now
we're saying let's put it up online and
let's make it available and let's make
it searchable this is hard for a lot of
people to do we have huge backlogs on
things like FOIA where we now have a lot
what's for you a Freedom of Information
Act excuse me so the traditional process
by which people have filed requests for
information which in many cases have
gone unanswered for a long time and
therefore have you know just created
huge paper backlogs and requesting
information that people even if they
want to make it available can't find it
because it's in a shoebox somewhere so I
think that there is you know this is a
it's a really a mixed bag where there
was a great deal of enthusiasm both from
the bottom and from the top and a lot of
difficulty because of just
institutionalized inertia that's we
haven't had the practice of doing it we
haven't had the tools to do it before
and in many cases you know again
remember the first blog in 2008 so if
people want to do something like create
a blog or you know it's in many cases a
huge lift for them to figure out how to
do this within the strictures of
government procurement practices of of
rules about who can speak and who can't
speak and just questions about are we
allowed to do this that people aren't
used to doing but I think there's a real
kind of contagion at least from where I
sit that seems to be catching fire and
the great part about this is again keep
in mind data.gov created by the 80 CIOs
not by the White House the open
government plans created by every agency
not by the Office of Management and
Budget and the reporting requirement
under the open government directive is
not to the Office of Management and
Budget it's to the American people you
must put this up on the web and make it
available to your constituents not to
some small office within the White House
so in that's the hope is that we bring
about distributed change through a
process of creating enthusiasm and
contagion and really just catalyzing the
desire for innovation that already
exists do you keep saying the American
people
the internet doesn't really have
international boundaries and presumably
there's a fair amount of you know
certainly observation and maybe also
participation from people outside the
borders we how are you with that well is
it good or bad if you gave a Haiti
example and so you know we're sort of
engaging with Haiti and that starts to
soften that border but you know English
speakers all over the world are they
participating in the US government so
sure if you have I mean if it's if you
have a good idea for how to solve the
problem and you aren't in New Jersey but
you're in Croatia then if it solves my
problem I'm thrilled to hear from you is
so this this is you know to the point
about the Croatia comes to mind somehow
because America's Army you may recall
this video game that was created was
most played by people in Croatia even
though it was designed to help the army
identify recruits for the US Army so if
you were really good really good
pointing skills they would call you up
and say would you like to join they
turned out that all the play are the
best players in Croatia but that's an
aside some of whom probably emigrated
and are now in the military entirely
possible um so that's exactly the point
I mean the communities you know the use
of the term the American people is an
artifact of my now working in Washington
we like to talk about the American
people um it is the it are those are the
people who actually pay pay our salaries
and whom we are in here to serve but of
course we are part of a world community
and that's where these I think a more
networked approaches in fact helped us
evolve towards the new kind of
government that we will see if we're
talking long term now that will not
respect the kind of national
sovereignties that we know today so I
think that's a that's a slightly longer
term vision but that's what we're here
to do this relates to a question from
Kevin Kelly are there any national
governments anywhere that are role
models for you and I guess the other
part of that question is what is or your
activities starting to be a role model
for other national governments
absolutely so a lot of this the thinking
about kind of participatory engagement
and involvement comes out of Europe
it doesn't come from the United States
so if we think about the sort of
participatory worker culture that
developed in the Scandinavian countries
in the 70s I think that has been some of
the inspiration I think also there are
institutionalized practices you know
more in theory than in practice in terms
of their success at using citizen
engagement and participation that
European countries have long recognized
that have had if you look at media
policy for example in the way that it's
created in Europe at all media policy in
these you know public media systems have
a citizen engagement component to them
again they've not worked as well in
practice but the notion at least in
theory of involving citizens and
decision making has been around for
quite a number of years as a way of
improving the way the political
institutions work now in terms of who's
really at the forefront of doing doing
open government England Australia a lot
of the english-speaking countries when
it comes to better service delivery and
what we sometimes think about his ego
vermin using technology to ensure that
you can pay your taxes faster or pay
your parking tickets faster Singapore of
course has been in the lead on this for
a long time so in terms of understanding
how to use technology to do more
efficient government on there several
countries Canada and Singapore from whom
we've done a lot of learning but I do
have to say and this hasn't part to do
with the appeal and the star power and
the popularity of the brilliance of our
president and I'm totally biased in this
regard that his the fact that he stands
for this agenda is I think helping a
great deal to spread the concept of open
government to governments at the state
and local level in this country and
abroad and elsewhere that's really kind
of catching fire and the moment is now
you know it's this is we live in a
certain technical technological time in
which the notion as I said earlier you
know this is we're transforming the
music industry in the publishing
industry and journalism it's only about
time that our political institutions
might be infected with the same fever a
couple questions on innocence values of
non openness Janet Crain as it has been
proposed that the more egalitarian and
transparent Congress becomes the less
able they are to pass farsighted
legislation deals aren't made in front
of TV cameras and politicians become
locked into publicly pronounced partisan
this please comment in relation to that
kevin kelly asks is there a role for
secrecy secrecy non transparency in the
collaborative democracy is there a
mechanism for determining when the call
for secrecy is correct and when it's
just an excuse
sorry two versions there Washington's
deals were made in backrooms
right well this was one of the
complaints after covered the government
in the Sunshine Act was passed that
provided for openness of meetings of
senior government leaders is two things
happened one is people stopped having
meetings they do deals over lunch and
the other is that people in one level
below the people who weren't covered by
the law that's where the actually
dealing would get done because it didn't
wasn't subject to the same strictures so
the question is when you mandate
transparency does it for certain
dealings into the backroom inevitably
because people do need a certain degree
of a deliberative privacy if you will
and I have to say I think that's you
know it's absolutely true if you if you
look at I'll give you another example
that in an attempt at avoiding to answer
this very hard question the Federal
Advisory Committee Act is what directs
the Constitution of what are called
federal advisory committees they're
about a thousand of them that provide
largely scientific expertise to
government agencies they're about 65,000
experts who serve the government and
you've heard about these more in the
context of the abuse of these committees
in the last administration where they
were stacked with industry
representatives and lobbyists instead of
with experts scientific experts in the
field is there the creation of these are
covered by the Federal Advisory
Committee Act which is intended to
provide greater transparency and
sunlight about their dealings so
everything they do is totally open and
the proceedings are open and the public
is invited to come in for the most part
and a lot of people complain that they
can't get anything done when they're
under the microscope because people are
afraid to appear stupid they're afraid I
mean either they're grandstanding for
the cameras that's the partisan
political comment but even in these
other contexts they're afraid to just
have a conversation and really try to
arrive at some kind of consensus it's
also the question that we've debated as
we start to think about putting visitor
logs up online putting Travels
schedules up online putting meetings up
online webcasting you know at what point
does it become counterproductive because
you spent so much time being open and
not enough time actually getting your
job done and so I think that there is
we're feeling our way towards the right
answer of what will allow people to
continue to be productive in their day
to day work we face this for example in
our office where we wanted to put every
meeting that we public meeting that we
did online but if every time I see
somebody do I need to put that online or
not or am i spending then all the time
or you know hiring so many interns
frankly to put all that stuff up online
that I never get anything else done and
so I think that there is a balance
between what is productive and what is
not and we have to definitely just feel
our way towards the right answer in many
cases so we've started with things like
lobbying reform and ensuring that when
we're talking to lobbyists that they're
we're much more open and we're declaring
when those meetings are taking place
than just when we're going you know to
lunch with our colleagues or whatnot so
these are hard questions to which we
don't entirely have the answer we know
that something's not functioning right
now and the you know bickering kind of
Internet's and political fighting that
in you know I don't think simply has to
do with the cameras but has to do with
the financing of our political system
and the short term you know nature of
our electoral cycles and therefore the
grandstanding for the cameras that takes
place this is all related but I think
it's a hard problem institutional
redesign that we just have to grapple
with how about secrecy Kevin Kelley
raises this point that lots of times
secrecy is an excuse to make various
things happen not just around
intelligence and Defense Department the
national security requires that we don't
let you know that whatever happens and
that's such an easy thing to do well I
don't so first there are real cases of
there are real national security issues
and problems and the threats are very
real I sit in an office that has bomb
blast curtains to catch the glass for
when somebody blows up my building so
the the sense of danger is you know and
the and the notion of danger is very
real on the threat to our virtual
networks as well as our physical plant
is serious so we do have to take it
seriously very much so
but as an excuse you know I think this
is part of the cultural shift that we're
undergoing it is much easier now to say
national security sorry but as we begin
to see this contagion spreading and we
are requiring every agency to go down
the path of at least inventory ins
information and talking about what
information it's not going to release
and we start to make it more regular
practice in status quo to put
information on raw online and reward the
people who put the information online we
begin to create a culture so by doing
things like showcasing them on the you
know create you know the the the you
know that on the west coast all you have
to do is get people a t-shirt right and
then they will do anything for you so we
haven't quite learned that in Washington
yet but we do put them on the White
House website and showcase the work that
they do we do have award ceremonies we
do now have as part of the open
government directive one of the things
that we're doing is looking at how do we
institutionalize the process of giving
prizes in government so that we have the
legal basis to actually give people
prizes and recognition for the work that
they're doing so I think it's by
creating a positive culture around
transparency that we begin to make it
more and more difficult to use secrecy
as an excuse and the best thing is is
that once we put things out there it
becomes very difficult to put the genie
back in the bottle that's the hope is
that once you make it available you
can't then stop the spigot of data
flowing if you're releasing that
economic information today you can't
stop doing it tomorrow without raising a
hue and cry so you know an evolutionary
process but again it's where the open
government directive specifically says
that agencies are to release data in
response to public demand so if you
don't ask for it you won't see it happen
as fast as you would like so don't
complain you know get involved actually
do complain yeah I've heard you design a
t-shirt today you wanted to have a
teacher's I hurt data and you have a
line in your slides that love data lasts
longer what's that about so you you're
that's do you want to tell us what
that's about I stole that from you so
they
I'm curious to see what you're gonna do
with it well this is the met the mashing
up right so the the notion love data
last longer is again the this idea that
if we put the data out there it's one
thing to make raw data available but raw
data by itself isn't that interesting
its data that's loved by somebody it's
you know somehow the gorge of data if
you will I love it I'll squeeze it I'll
hold it what's that Bugs Bunny line that
I'm not allowed to use an illusion that
I can't remember though the words to I'm
so jet-lagged that should not have gone
down that road but the notion that if we
actually embrace the data sets and use
it to make the kinds of mashups that are
being done by stayman design I see you
guys sitting over there and if you
actually turn around and take the crime
data from Oakland and from San Francisco
and turn around and make it visual and
visible so that people can see the
conditions in their own neighborhoods
that's the loving that data and frankly
that is a labor of love that has gone
into creating these kinds of volunteer
projects that we turn around and we
actually take the data the raw data from
our health care system and HHS is
putting out more and more data every day
now and we turn around and use that to
create visualizations of comparative
effectiveness of our healthcare system
so that we can understand why does a hip
replacement cost more in one community
than it does in another that allows us
to then understand better how to create
greater efficiencies in our healthcare
system
it's that kind of loving of the data
that we need to do that not all of us
can do or want to do but that actually
help us make more informed political
decisions that may help us make you know
our political system work better for all
of us so that's what I mean by love data
what do you mean by love data just that
you can see the original pioneering
videogames have been kept alive by
people who started to love them when
they were young and they've developed
emulators online where you can play pong
or whatever the hell it is even though
it's you know 16 platforms later and
that's a key so basically public
adopting a thing and then keeping it
alive and definitely just by using it
and loving it so I have to tell you I
own an island in Second Life my
Institute it's an island in Second Life
and called democracy Island it will not
surprise you and our developers had the
most wonderful idea that every year we
would just take the island and we'll
float it above the island and then we'll
create a new island underneath and so we
will have a vertical historical record
of the space that you could traverse
much like these sort of you can do on
your Mac desktop but we've created a or
I think we've envisioned doing this a 3d
layer of a physical virtual space
instead of up in the air how about down
in the water so it's kind of a series of
Atlantis's that you discover is going I
don't think there are second life
underground prims there are above-ground
prims but not I don't think you could
terraform look for that demand
underground all right - just a damn
minute questions from John Gilmore
he said one is if science matters
why does Obama's Department DOJ argue
that the data quality Act doesn't allow
citizens to challenge incorrect data in
facts that have policy implications and
how can the US government claim any
transparency at all when an in acts
hides and enforces secret laws most of T
essays rules are not only secret that
they actively lie to the public about
what they say for example you must show
photo ID to fly
I was a predictable question from job
the what was the first one the first one
oh DOJ and the OData quality doesn't
allow citizens challenged and correct
incorrect and in fact so we I have to
know a little bit more about what the
question is because in fact data quality
at least under this administration the
Office of Information and regulatory
affairs in the Office of Management and
Budget which has authority to enforce
the data quality Act is a huge driver
essentially it's a in fact one of the
slowdowns if you will of getting data up
online is is you know in the perfect can
be the enemy of the good of the good is
to inspect the data make sure the data
quality is good and to provide now
though a public feedback mechanism on
data.gov for issues of data quality so
in other words you can go on and say I
found a problem with this data set and
so we have created a participatory
mechanism for enforcing data quality and
challenging the quality of data sets but
this is a brand new initiative I mean
it's just since May last May that we've
started doing this of creating an open
vehicle for providing these kinds of
challenges to data quality that you
don't have to go to court because you
may know that the data quality Act was
in someone this is a you know kind of
debatable point among legal academics
but in many cases has been used in the
last number of years to hold up the
regulatory process so to allow large
companies to challenge the scientific
validity of data as a way to prevent
regulation from going forward so we've
tried to do is in order to not open up
the floodgates of litigation I used to
create an open mechanism using the web
to actually allow people to challenge
the quality of data and in turn we have
to turn that into a more participatory
mechanism for reworking data sets
finding problems in the Met cetera there
is I want to commend to people the
concept of operations for data.gov which
is a if you have the stomach for it a
seventy page document that is really
quite detailed and wonderful that
outlines how data.gov works and where
it's going from here and it's open for
public participation and comment and
particularly on these issues of data
quality OMB is very concerned to ensure
that we do get this right so there is a
lot of openness and receptivity to this
and as for TSA
the and the ID policy I recognized the
know I know I know about the battle over
the I know about this this is legendary
and I actually tried it I have a newborn
child and so I'd wanted to see whether
he had to show data when I when he hit
show data here to show iid when I flew
yesterday to get out here but that's a
so I was I did have your interest at
heart when I test your implanted in an
RFID and in metals TSA assumed that I
planted a bomb in him is that the so you
know again there is now a very open
highly receptive you know opportunity
now to rear a z-- these questions to
discuss them again and to do them in an
open way so I wouldn't view that the
practices and policies of last eight
years have to be the policies and the
practices going forward so without
speaking to the specifics of this issue
which is totally above my paygrade
the I do want to say that you know now
is an opportunity to re-raise a lot of
questions that may have been raised
before but we are in a new era and TSA
and DHS have a phenomenal new leadership
and among the agencies that are really
at the forefront you know on the data on
eight dhs.gov slash open Janet
Napolitano herself is there presenting
the open government plan I mean it's one
of the agencies where this is from the
Secretary on down there is a lot of
commitment to figuring out how to do
openness right within the agency there's
a kind of a managerial question that has
several levels to it Mike
looks like Cooney offski how do you set
up the incentive so that the people who
participate in these online forums and
so on are not just the angry once we
have a lot of time on their hands
and you know that noe if we see it in
you know in every blog in the comments
thereafter but frankly the public
discourse is dominated to a large extent
by nitwits you know and if we can't fix
one how can we fix the other I think
they are connected absolutely and I
don't want to sound you know in my
responses excessively Pollyanna if you
can be excessively Pollyanna about yes
you can yeah I want to sound as
enthusiastic as I am and as committed as
I am to doing this which is why you have
to really believe in it to get up every
day and really do this and fight for
this kind of culture shift against a
long historical you know period that
precedes this one that has not believed
in these these sorts of values of
openness and we have the problem that
not only do we have an institutionalized
culture within government but we have a
civil society that has frankly gotten
used to the way that government operates
right so we have a whole series of civil
society organizations that have learned
how to fight the power in the way that
the power was organized right and so
that's why what we're used to is our
view of engagement is to give money to
organizations that in turn lobby
Congress because that's the way the
system has worked and has called upon us
to engage and you have a lot of those
organizations so I think are complicit
in the process of successively
centralizing power because they want to
build mailing lists and membership and
organization because it's how they're
used to working because it's you know
how the system is worked so our level of
civic discourse are is is problematical
because we haven't had the maturation
process that's allowed us to develop
these sorts of skills yet there's a sign
on the door to my office my old one was
taken down and what it's replaced with
is Beth Novak director intergalactic
policy area 51 and the reason I earned
this title is because when we launched
the open government participatory
engagement process we said how much our
open government policy be and people
said that you should release the records
on the UFOs that have landed so and you
should tell us where Obama birth
certificate is and it's probably on a
UFO somewhere so we
got out of the birthers or the UFO folks
or the kennedy conspiracy theorist
kennedy assassination conspiracy
theorists were all on day one that's
what we heard from and so it was funny
but it was also sad at the same time but
the other what happened was over the
course of the evolution of that process
is by virtue of the fact that we're now
using tools that allow communities to
self moderate their discussions and to
do things like flag things that are
off-topic
and move them to another page and that
we have evolved our thinking in terms of
how this then relates to the First
Amendment because we're allowing people
to self moderate rather than government
to censor that we actually then the
community stepped up and began to
moderate out those comments and that
allowed when you moved away the weeds
the plants could grow and the community
itself began to flourish and the
relevant comments you know emerge and I
think what we've seen then the sort of
crazy people with who were excited by
having a whitehouse.gov megaphone in
front of them began to recede into the
background but I think there is a larger
question about how we evolve our civic
culture to match the challenge of our
institutional culture at the same time
we see lots of it emerging within techie
space the people who are doing crisis
camps and doing hackathons and you know
going out and doing data mashups but I
think there's a long way for that to
kind of trickle through the rest of our
culture lots to be done hacker culture
takes over government that's a
tomorrow's headline Washington Post's
you senior government officials so you
know know what you learn you learn about
being a government is that if you can be
misquoted you will be right plus the
name of everybody in the audience will
also be in the Washington Post tomorrow
right mark L asks corporations have as
much power and control over our lives as
government if not more yet they are
largely allowed to operate a near total
internal secrecy how can we make them
transparent in ways necessary for us to
govern and interact safely with them
yeah good about it good question all
right
so the so one thing is there's a kind of
reciprocal whole thing going on here so
a lot of this kind of ideation
brainstorming stuff we're learning from
companies who do this you know it's the
Netflix prizes of the world that where
companies there are some very successful
companies that are embracing openness
and in the ways that they work now to
the point about spending transparency
the kind of fraud waste and abuse part
of things a lot of companies or most
companies are very reluctant to do
anything but that which is demanded of
them by law in terms of opening
themselves up so the question is how
does this agenda then translate into a
stronger regulatory enforcement agenda
the creation of the kinds of protections
for example the president having signed
into law greater financial transparency
a greater transparency for credit card
companies for banks and the movement now
towards greater consumer protection the
call now for a new consumer regulatory
consumer protection regulatory agency
that will precisely try to do exactly
this so we have to see you know this is
I think one of the things that we have
to demand of our legislators of our
executive branch of our government and
of our companies that we do try to
institute you know greater transparency
throughout all sectors of life so here
here to the comment ending was a kind of
a long now question how has policy of
openness and transparency two main be
maintained past the political party
swing that has occurred in every other
past exchange of terms and parties and
so on back and forth how do you embed
this right so something we're very
conscious of because you know in every
administration as I sort of alluded to
but not explicitly enough we every
Attorney General comes out and
promulgates a rule on the Freedom of
Information Act and so from Party to
party with change of parties the rule on
openness under the Freedom of
Information Act has changed and now
under Attorney General Holder subsequent
to the memorandum on open government
Holder comes out and says the default
rule will be open and not only that but
government agencies must proactively
start working to put data up online and
we turn around in the open government
directive
and say that that means online means in
open accessible formats so not locked up
in proprietary formats but made
available openly for people to download
and to mash up and to do things with but
as I alluded to I think just having a
policy by itself is not enough because
it changes with the political winds of
time but it's when you start putting the
data sets out there when you have a
platform like data.gov where you can see
and quantify and measure who's putting
up what data and how many people are
putting up what data and we've created
just now version 0.5 of the open
government dashboard which is intended
to track the progress towards open
government over time I say 0.5 because
right now it's tracking the it's
tracking simply the basic requirements
under the open government directive but
we know that we are you know going to
evolve this and are working across the
agencies to develop a stretch criteria
if you will
bolder ways that we can actually measure
our own progress of letting that genie
out of the bottle it's when you have the
platforms like a data gov or when you
have every agency running an idea scale
open policy making process that it
becomes very difficult I think I hope to
undo these things it's hard to turn the
tap off once you've turned it on once
you get people used to the concept of
doing public engagement before they make
a decision it becomes hard than to stop
doing that
or then we need to start asking
questions about why did you stop doing
something that you started and
politicians at least we use the sort of
sure we have to use the Jujitsu of
responding to the incentives of
short-term thinking to affect the
long-term change so the short-term
thinking is how do I get reelected
search I'm thinking is how do I keep my
job what do I do today and so you people
don't like their name to appear in the
wha-hoo headlines of the Washington Post
unless it's for doing something good and
so the way that you keep them out of the
headlines is to ensure that they are
keeping the taps turned on because when
they turn them off when the data stops
flowing when the citizen engagement
stops happening when they're not being
responsive to the things that you're
asking me about and we've you know
stretch to our next lay out by saying
that we will do this because the
opportunity to have to be to fail at
this agenda and to be held accountable
because frankly there are a million
things we could put up online and for
everything we put up online there will
be something else that we haven't done
that somebody will want and complain
about and so we are actively seeking
that complaint if you will we're
actively seeking that collaboration of
working together to push ourselves
higher to the next level so that over
the long term we make it very difficult
to go back to the way that our
institutions work before I have to say
and again this may be you know from
where I sit and that helps me to get
this job done and to do this work is
that we have already changed the culture
and government beyond the point of
recognition of where it was a year ago
it is a different place and when you
talk to people it is so inspiring to
hear from people how excited they are by
public service now and that's again in
part because of this president because
of the political momentum that he
generated but it's because of the work
that each individual in government that
they now can do and that's now being
rewarded in terms of embracing and
rewarding and celebrating innovation
it's the fact that the Department of
Labor gave out snow globes last week to
all the employees who went in during the
blizzard and I don't know why this would
have captured my imagination I loved the
idea of a snow globe somehow that was
celebrating Snowmageddon to the people
Snowmageddon 2010 to the people who went
in and did their job above and beyond
the call of the call service it's the
guys who run the federal register who
now are making this data set available
and are so excited to have do you know
what it's like if you've been publishing
the Federal Register that PDF document
that all these years people said Oh
boring who cares about that and the
bowels of the federal and the bowels of
the National Archives and now they're on
the front page of whitehouse.gov and
everybody's talking about it and their
Gulf Pulse guys are making mashup tools
based on what they've done and people
care about the Federal Register it's
exciting people love those data sets and
for the people in government whose job
it is to make that data and to collect
it to suddenly be heroes I think it is a
wonderful wonderful time to be involved
in public service it's a wonderful time
to be part of a process of institutional
reinvention and the more that we can do
to both offer a key the carrot and the
stick of that to foster long-term change
I think the better off we'll be to get
us to the next level which will look
like something quite different than
anything we know today I just imagined
every bureaucrat with their own fan club
which would change a lot of things but
do you want to ask one further question
which is and it is raised by this there
is oscillation in government one of the
things that the reason that I think two
parties emerged even though it's not in
the Constitution is is it one way of
maintaining a kind of a balance over
time is with oscillations in time so we
get a lot of regulation and then there's
a period of deregulation and that's
worth doing because not all the
regulations without wonderful and or
they become outdated and so on so we'll
get a period of great openness and then
presumably there'll be a period of
biographies with a conservative
government already knows of cutting back
on some of the openness and then more
but different openness with new
platforms and so on and so forth are
there ways to kind of build in the hooks
in the software than the technology and
in since in the management and in the
expectations that this is a ongoing
evolving process that will is not going
to get locked in in the present mode the
mode will keep changing and the mode is
aware that is supposed to keep changing
is their way to do that kind of meta
management question which I think may be
a common you know you the question may
itself be the answer in some ways let me
say first of all that if you saw David
Cameron's TED talk that this is this is
a if you will a post partisan agenda in
many respects so it's the conservatives
now and in the UK who are campaigning on
a platform of openness right so it's the
you know the anti moat a mission if you
will nobody's the moats though all the
parliamentarians who were buying they're
doing their moat cleaning with taxpayer
dollars that was uncovered recently in
the UK so the push towards transparency
is in many respects an issue that is
that is shared by both left and right in
many respects so it's it's something
that I think we can agree on but I think
you are right that we do have to view
this as a dynamic
and changing an evolving process I mean
you know I don't I don't really know I'd
be interested to know what it's a good
question about how we think about that
but I I would say a few things one is
just that the consciousness that we are
engaged in a process of change that is
highly experimental and experimental is
not a word that we frequently associate
with government it's a word that makes a
lot of people uncomfortable because
we're government we're supposed to know
how to do it we're supposed to be the
experts right so feeling our way groping
our way towards new institutional design
is an unusual kind of concept but it
also keeps us humble I think it allows
us to realize that we really are
figuring out as we go and we know that
when it comes to things like engagement
and participation we don't have the
tools to do it we don't have them know
how how to do it we don't have the
practices for how to do it yet these
aren't evolved yet so for all the people
there's now I'm on a listserv where
people are discussing these ideation
platforms and there's a lot of criticism
is IdeaScale the right tools should you
use this tool or that tool
how does this work and etc and I think
it's wonderful because the opportunity
to say we don't know how to do
brainstorming right within government
and what if the issue is a highly
scientific issue what if it's a highly
value driven issue what if it requires
short answers or longer answers because
we haven't had the institutional
practice with actually connecting
institutions to networks before not
really in the way and at the scale that
we can do now so yes Thomas Jefferson
wrote the letter to the patent examiner
I'm excuse me to the professor in 1791
but the concept now of a large-scale
institutional shift is one that we have
to do with a high degree of humility
enthusiasm but humility going forward
and recognizing that it has to be an
evolving process and so one of the other
things that's great about the people
that I work with is that they truly
believe that in rough consensus running
code in other words we got updated gov
in May we started in January and we got
it up in May and that was you know but
in January we didn't even know I
couldn't even find my office at that
point you know we were trying to fair
where the light switch was to get it
done that fast knowing that we would
start and we would go from there
to start this open government
participatory discussion with tools that
we
cobbled together out of what was freely
available with no existing
infrastructure to do it and we basically
we took what was free that would
basically do the job and we cobbled
together three things that force people
to sign on to three different tools and
there was no common interface and so
everybody know there's no common
interface and the design is terrible in
all this but we did something and we
started the ball rolling and when people
saw that oh the White House put up their
data or the White House did a citizen
engagement where they're releasing the
visitor logs that in turn you know it's
rough consensus running code version 0.5
open government this year version 1.0
and we'll see where we go over the next
seven years what I love is we're no
longer discussing this in theory we're
discussing it in practice because of you
thank you thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]